come on daddy hello everybody today
we're gonna go visit Jenna take judge
the job park and who knows what else
because I am not really sure what's
gonna happen today guess what I found my
iPhone 7 dongle it's been missing for
quite some time this also just came in
today this is a USB type-c hub it has
many different slots for pretty much
everything that you're going to need
here has got one of the new MacBook Pros
or if you have one of the MacBook Airs
you can power it with USB see you get
two different SD card slots and two USB
slots hello I was telling Matt and Jenna
that they have to get this so now I'm
going to take it and convince them that
this is a vineyard are we ready to go
booth a a little boy so we've got a new
location here for the GoPro in the car
Maddie what do you think of this but we
like it here you like the GoPro here
this is a nice angle we do we get you
over good angles
well how's this in the center does this
look a little better I have no idea I
just don't know because clearly and
drivings I can't actually see what it
looks like I'm sure it's just wonderful
or is it
you
[Music]
are we gonna go to the dog park yeah
let's do it
guys my vlogs are always the same how do
you daily vlog when you do the same
thing every day you got adventures let's
do it
but like what do we do you didn't you
didn't see peopIe Street forced
activities underlying depression and
drove shots that's what we need to add
to our vlog it was a great it was a
great tweet well this is why I don't
think vlog so let's go to the dog park
that's that's step one daddy will be
over here honey
yeah that has new friends yeah I got a
new crayons now you've got a new for now
do I get a new friend no dog Oh looks
like the dog no dog maddie is with Jenna
right now and it was kind of weird as I
was sitting here just on my computer and
I had this thought I was like oh my god
where's Maddie I haven't seen him in a
while now you staying with Jenna I have
some meetings tomorrow so instead of
leaving you here by himself
she said that she would watch him so
that's what's happening tomorrow I
thought I was gonna have enough footage
today for a full vlog why is this look
weird but I really didn't I didn't
really do much today it did a lot of
cleaning did some work did some emails
had to do with a few things that have
happened to my youtube channel but don't
worry it's all fixed right now I'm
downloading overwatch on my PC doing
updates something that I'm pretty
excited about Xbox anywhere I wanted to
play Gears of War but I'm gonna be
traveling so I can just play it on my PC
laptop instead because Xbox anywhere not
sponsored I've got like this ridiculous
list of games that I want to play and
just absolutely no time to do it I don't
I don't know where the time goes like I
could go and work in my actual office
but when I travel so much I feel like
it's sometimes just easier to edit and
work how I normally would work when I'm
on the go
Oh No this is where we are I've got some
really great news because the propellers
came in for the GoPro Karma if you
missed the tragic crash there are so
many people in the comments blaming this
or that saying that Justine the camera
was facing you so clearly you probably
were pushing the sticks the opposite way
and that's why it ran into the house
that was definitely not the case because
I've learned from my mistake everyone
also said it's because the GPS signal
I've flown a lot of drones actually in
that little backyard area and it wasn't
something that I'd planned on taking up
very far I'd just wanted to get a shot
just see what the camera looked like
mostly I took it up because I wanted to
see what the audio sound like with DJI
drones you don't get audio but since the
GoPro was attached to the Karma you'll
be able to have audio it's not gonna be
usable at all but I just want to see how
loud it was and if it actually would at
all be usable at any point ever it's
really not no I can't wait for the new
MacBooks to come in I just keep thinking
about how much I love it this is how I
spend my evenings ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls I'm also excited to see
is how the footage today from my car
ride went you guys have already seen it
because I've already been in the video
but I have not what you're about to open
this up this is superlight unfortunately
I don't have a USB C port on either of
these computers so I can't even test
this out basically this is gonna be
pretty awesome for the new MacBook Pro I
got the space grey color he's originally
made for the MacBook Airs but you
basically are just gonna stick this in
right here and it's got all the ports
were gonna need not very many those I
might have to get another one of these I
just realized the last night I never
finished talking about the footage that
I was gonna look at cuz I fell asleep
Maddie's back back again I'm looking for
a knife right now my propellers have
come in last night I watched a YouTube
video it was like this 45-minute insane
review of the Karma and basically this
guy had the same problem that I had and
he basically says it's trash so I kind
of say you need to watch this review
that this guy did of the GoPro Karma did
you watch it no I miss sleeping silly
it's very very funny look guys for
hanging out having a good time so
basically I'm gonna be playing overwatch
on my lap on my laptop and that's gonna
be laying on the floor watching his
phone and Jenna's watching arrow we
don't hang out separately am i ordering
pizza they have meatball sliders fresh
fries wedge cut now Matt doesn't like
meatballs
they've monster like ground sirloin you
brought their mozzarella sticks I'm
gonna play my overwatch tutorial now
thank you what play overwatch actually a
can you think why can't I play it well
the problem is you're gonna run into now
is the fact anyone's gonna be good now
hear me out okay you're playing on a
laptop with a controller so you're not
going playing with the Xbox people
you're playing with the PC players yeah
and they all have keyboard and mouse
a--'s so they're gonna be a lot better
than it's a valid point but I can also
play it on my computer upstairs if I
want to yeah but right now I'm playing
on my lap I know I do you think I would
just yeah I'm just saying you're gonna
get rolled like you're not gonna get
killed I'm gonna get a kill Matt how's
this uh how's this baseball game going
God there are three Oh at the top of the
first it's unbelievable don't got
something under here hey no don't
now look let's just stay with me honey
stay with no long I've got treats hey
don't don't lie to him I'm one right
there's one and Matt it's over it's over
oh I know Cubs are up seven two cheese
good I'm really glad for you fine mother
I think I want to bring this vlog to an
end because I'm not sure what even it
all was so I hope you guys enjoyed
whatever was in this video Maddie's
looking at me cuz he knows that we're
ending the video
end of the video Maddie man I've been
really great in white chocolate pretzels
today they were delicious okay guys see
you later peace whyever uh-oh
you're what a washed-up Call of Duty Pro
you're supposed to be something that
you're not
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry that was the best verb 2016
you gotta keep it in the video that was
incredible high five